[Music]
so if I had only two words to sum up how
we think about security in Google cloud
it's this it would be trust nothing so
as you start moving your services to
Google cloud the first thing you do is
obviously secure your VPC you'd secure
connectivity to your VPC you'd apply
really granular policies with I am
kubernetes engine network policies and
more and one of the most important
things that you would do after this is
to secure your internet facing apps now
this is actually a tough job because you
do need to serve your users fast but
then at the same time you need to block
out DDoS and application attacks and
this will be the focus of our talk today
so how can you defend your services
against a protocol volume metric and
then application DDoS attacks so this is
what it looks like now this is actually
a graph that is drawn based on the DDoS
attacks on Google's own services so
services such as search and YouTube and
Gmail and of course our security experts
work round the clock to protect Google's
own services from these attacks and as
you can see the attacks are growing
exponentially in valve volume and not
just in this respect but also in respect
to packets per second or any of the
other parameters and you can notice that
this scale is already past one point
seventy bps so one of the things I did
was to ask our DDoS defense lead like
what does absorbing a huge DDoS attack
feel like and he says absorbing a large
DDoS attack it requires the bandwidth
needed to watch half a million YouTube
videos all at the same time in high
definition so that's what it feels like
now if you look at this these are all of
the Google services and partner
solutions that you have at your disposal
to go defend against all of these
attacks the only one I'm not going to
cover in this talk is the last one which
is project shield but that is actually
our free service that uses Google's
technology to protect new sites and
of expression from DDoS and other
attacks so the first best practice that
we recommend for your internet facing
services is to start with a global load
balancer and with TLS everywhere so
wherever possible use TLS and then as it
relates to the load balancer you would
use either our HTTP load balancer or if
your traffic is non HTTP so let's say
you're running smtp then you would
actually run the ssl proxy load balancer
and both of these are again global load
balancing flavors which means you can
put your backends in any region you want
and you confront them with a single whip
which gives you also a single point to
apply all of your policies we also have
several features including SSL policies
so you can restrict for instance
specific ciphers or you can restrict
certain TLS versions and this is
especially important for important for
PCI compliance so we put in our global
HTTP HTTPS load balancer we put in our
policies the next thing that you would
want to layer in is cloud armor now this
is a new service that we introduced
recently and if you think of what it
provides you obviously need the table
stakes l3 and l4 DDoS defense which is
actually really hard to defend against
in addition to that you need something
that's very extensible where you can
express what your intent is so that is
why there's a policy framework in a
rules language and then you have your
features such as blacklist whitelist or
you maybe you want to control access
based on geo and then you have your raf
protection and with all of this you
obviously want to know what's going on
so there's the telemetry aspect of it
and with all of this then you can also
layer in a product that we call identity
aware proxy so this is based on beyond
caught which is how identity is handled
inside Google and then if you layer all
of these three together one of the other
things that you would do is you have
your V PC or you have your instances in
your V PC and you would configure the
firewalls on those instances to only
allow traffic through the load balancer
because you put all of these our knobs
at the load balancer
and you want to ensure that no other
internet facing traffic actually leaks
to your back ends so let's talk a little
bit about cloud armor the first thing as
I mentioned is that it gives you a
policy framework what you can see here
is a snip of our G cloud console and
Google console and then you can see the
three policies that exist in there if
you start zooming in on these policies
the first thing is you can apply a cloud
armor policy for a given back-end
service so let's say we've got four
services maybe these are your four
internet-facing services you could
choose to reuse this policy let's say
you define a policy called cloud our
policy p1 you could choose to use it for
web service one you define a policy p2
and you used it for your service two and
then you define a policy p3 but maybe
it's applicable to multiple services so
you can reuse the same policy for
multiple services as you see as you can
see in there if you look closely at any
of those policies what you would notice
is that a policy comprised of a
hierarchy of rules and then within each
rules you have something that you match
the traffic against and then there's an
action that you take based on whether
there's a match or not so the actions
could be allow the traffic deny the
traffic we also have an interesting
option called preview and what that does
is lets you test out rules so if you
configure the preview option there it
would simply log the action will
actually not take it on your traffic so
if you're testing out the rules that's
probably what you would start with to
begin with now when we started talking
about building out you know almost a way
to go Express the rules we thought about
using a variety of different tools some
were proprietary but then we decided to
use something that's not just flexible
but also open and we settled on cell
which is short for common expression
language if any of you have used
firebase you've already used cells so
that is what it's used for expressing
certain expressions and then once you
specify the rules using this language
cloud armor will then
use these rules to go orchestrate the
underlying global infrastructure and
then obviously that infrastructure is
going to allow a block your service
based on whatever it is you've
configured for the rule so what are the
types of things that you can actually do
with cloud armor the first thing that
you can do is you can either allow or
block traffic for IPS or ciders and this
could be either ipv4 addresses or ciders
or ipv6 as well so we support both if
you think of the other types of things
that you might want to do a very common
ask is for customers to be able to
control based on the geolocation so that
is what you see in here and you can
combine it with IP addresses using
operators like and or not one of the
other popular thing is how do we defend
ourselves against all of these
application attacks and so that is what
you see with the cross-site scripting
and the SQL injection defense this is
where again you can see the rule drools
language in action so there's a custom
rule that's crafted where it's looking
for us and then it's looking for certain
things in the user agent and then it's
looking for a certain type of cookie and
then you could choose to do either deny
or permit along with this one and then
the last important thing is once your
traffic is allowed or blocked it would
go lock this in stag driver and then it
would tell you which is the policy that
it matched which is the rule so the
priority is actually the rule number and
then what was the action that was taken
so once you have all of this in place it
is very easy to allow our block traffic
based on your unique requirements so I
wanted to actually give you a quick look
at what's under the hood and so this one
let's the first one is actually pretty
straightforward where essentially for
the l3 l4 you would turn on the global
DDoS defend in here let's turn on this
defense because what I want to show you
is actually what's coming next the
second thing is let's go and launch an
SQL injection attack or sequel injection
as some of you call it and in here it's
actually worse than just bringing your
service down because it would actually
go and also
to steal your data so I wanted to just
walk you through the back end of this to
show you what it looks like which is
let's go in here this is the actual UI
here you would go to this tab called
network security and then you can see
that we have a bunch of different
policies so these could have been just
rules in our policy or they can be
different policies itself let's look at
the one for sequel injection now if you
see in here the most important one is
the one you see in here which is
evaluate pre-configured expression so
you just need one rule and then under
the hood is going to look for 160
patterns to actually go and then block
the traffic of sequel injection the
other policy that I wanted to show you
is the one that I showed you briefly
on-screen which is this one and then if
you see in here the first rule so let's
go and try and edit that so if you look
at this rule and I will see if I can
zoom and so you can see it better so
when we start looking at our rules we
have two modes one of them is
essentially a basic mode which is the
one you see on top and that's simply if
you want to add a blacklist or whitelist
what is most important is actually this
advanced mode which is what you see here
and in the entire rules language that
you see actually can be used here so
this was the specific example where you
would look for traffic which is from us
and then where the user in agent
contains bad bot and then the request
headers the cookie itself contains the
specific value that you see in there
some of the other things I wanted to
point out is as I mentioned there was an
allow if you do a deny you can also look
through several of these and then figure
out what is the status code that you
want and then the preview mode you can
simply enable here and then the priority
would tell its order or its place inside
the hierarchy so you can see that on the
right here so that was basically a look
at what the policies look like and then
switching back to cloud armor and then
some of the things that we do with it
one of the most interesting things that
you can actually
with cloud armor is to combine it with
several of Google's technologies and
also combine it with several of our
partner solutions so while we won't have
enough time to go through solutions from
each of these partners you can see that
it ranges from Identity and Access
Management to scanning to governance
compliance even we have like you know
cows bees we've got things against us
fishing and so on so on our website we
actually describe each of these partner
solutions in great detail one of the
partners I specifically wanted to call
out is replays and replays provides a
web security solution so it's in use at
eBay and several of our other customers
and then of course it provides a
valproate DDoS protection anti string
it'll provide fine rain easy else one of
the really interesting bits about
replays is this that the architecture is
actually fully powered by GCP along with
a lot of value-added intelligence that
tree blaze brings to the solution so I
wanted to put this here so you can look
at some of the foundational building
blocks that come from GCP specifically
there are five services so there's
global node balancing there is CDN there
is cloud armor there is bigquery and
this machine learning now the global
load balancing provides the edge
infrastructure to absorb layer 3 and
layer 4 DDoS attacks and it also
provides a point to do TLS termination
now the bigquery is combined with
machine learning and then the kinds of
things that we'll do is like traffic
analysis in real time or application
analysis so this is where you want to
profile legitimate users and their input
and then make sure that it is something
that you can feed back into the valve it
will do real-time biometric data
analysis so this is used to tell for
instance bots apart from humans and
anytime once it detects something it
will use the cloud armor things such as
blacklist so your signatures and it will
delegate to cloud armor wherever
applicable and then what the main thing
it will give you is essentially defense
at the edge with this and then your
traffic or your bad traffic will never
reach your V PC and then you've got the
relays proxy instances which will run
all of the replay
value-added features that wouldn't get
delegated to any any of these systems so
the reason I wanted to show you this is
because this shows what is possible
using several of Google's technologies
especially global elbe cloud armor other
GCP services to harden your own posture
for your own services and then of course
you can complement each of these with
solutions from our partners so this was
a whirlwind tour of cloud armor and I
know we spoke about partners one of the
other things I wanted to talk about is
our customers and I think most of you
are aware that we announced target as
our customer at this GCP next and with
that I'm delighted to invite Nick a lead
engineer for target to come and describe
how they think about applications
security at target Thanks projector hi
so my name is Nick Jakes I'm a lead
engineer at target on our cloud platform
team just to give you a little context
around Who I am and what target is so
targets a pretty popular US retailer we
have over 1,800 stores in the US we also
have a good amount of distribution
centers in several headquarters
locations and a handful of data centers
I've been working on our cloud platform
team for about three years now and I
want to provide a little context around
timelines last year the very very
beginning of 2017 we kind of embarked on
this journey to migrate our workloads
from a variety of cloud providers into
GCP we were able to do that prior to
what we call peak season in 2017 so
before fall comes around and Black
Friday and all kinds of fun times around
the holidays and things went really well
so at the beginning of 2018 we thought
well we've migrated to non commerce
parts of our site so the parts of the
site that will help you search or browse
to find a product or we'll display
product images or reviews for you what
about the commerce part the part that
accepts credit card numbers the part
that lets you check out on the site all
kinds of things like that and we thought
this is something we should do too
our commerce environment was hosted in a
dedicated Cola facility and so we
thought it was time to modernize that so
at the beginning of 2018 around March we
embarked on that journey and we're
actually almost entirely done with it so
the vast part of target.com our mobile
apps and a good piece of our API is as
well have backends in target area and
GCP mm-hmm so moving on let's just kind
of do a little overview of targets
architectural patterns so the way that
we've kind of built things out is that
we basically have a CDN that fronts
everything that we have on the web so
all of our traffic comes through the CDN
we apply a variety of useful features
that the CDN provides things like
caching web out firewalls a massive
amount of logging and it also provides
us with some defense tactics so there we
can do rate limiting and we can also
blacklist so if we're seeing malicious
traffic or if we're seeing large volumes
of traffic we can handle it there the
CDN is also useful for us because target
has a multi cloud strategy so we have a
pretty big footprint of GCP but we don't
want to paint ourselves into the corner
and and so we want the ability to use
other CSPs
or for example if we have a trusted
third-party provider for pieces of our
site or certain functionality we want to
be able to direct that traffic to them
as needed and then finally the third
piece in this architecture is using the
l7 load balancer so I had a previous
talk just a few hours ago where we went
into a really deep dive about target's
architecture and GCP unfortunately no
one offers time travel as a service yet
so we can't go back but it will be
posted on YouTube so if you want to
really deep dive into target's
architecture and how we're using a lot
of the network functionality of DCP I
would encourage you to check that out
and in there you'll hear me just gush
about all the amazing things that these
load balancers do we don't have to worry
about pre-warming or scaling we don't
have to worry about regionalised load
balancers and then doing geolocation at
the edge and trying to figure out which
load balancer is closest to the user
things like that so it works really
great for us one of the amazing things
about this the
our teams really enjoy is the ability to
scale based on requests per second
coming in through the load balancer so
this is especially great if you have
services that for example don't hit the
CPU so you can't really auto scale based
on CPU but you know that a given
instance can only handle so much traffic
so you can scale it horizontally the
more requests are coming in to your load
balancer so let's move past that just a
little bit and now we're gonna start
talking about cloud armor so a really
important thing for target is that
security is for everyone it's for our
team members it's for our guests it's
for our team members who are our guests
it's for everyone that we interact with
so no matter what you're doing on target
comm or on the mobile apps or even using
our API API at target comm security is
really important and this is where a
cloud armor starts to come into play so
something was missing for us last year
cloud armor wasn't generally available
yet and so we were kind of sitting there
thinking hey these load balancers these
l7 load balancers are really great but
something's missing we can't apply
firewall rules to them so that means
that we don't have a way to only allow
traffic from our CDN for instance we
didn't really have a good method of
ingress control and like anything you
put out on the Internet we began to see
some kind of suspicious traffic you know
obviously some of its benign as people
just kind of port knocking and seeing
what's going on out there some of it not
so much so here you can see just a quick
snip from stack driver logs of traffic
that is denied a lot of lot of attempts
to try to get after a PHP myadmin
I took a little time and I try to
catalog some of these and now this isn't
a definitive list or anything like this
but we obviously we saw quite a bit of a
different basically attempts to see if
we had pH me my admin or WebDAV or even
Drupal installed and so luckily none of
this is actually making it to our
instances and our instances don't run
these pieces of applications but the
still isn't stuff that we aren't coming
in to our instances in the first place
right we don't want people knocking on
our door seeing what's going on there so
this kind of moves into knowing and
understanding traffic patterns obviously
there's a pretty wide spectrum in some
cases in some industries you can
classify things is known good based on
user interactions or
or source addresses or things like that
and in some cases you can classify
things is known bad again based on
sources or maybe you set a cookie or
something like that and for a lot of
industries there is a pretty wide gray
unknown in the middle in target's case
luckily we actually kind of fall over on
the left-hand side and the reason for
that is we have a pretty limited list of
criteria of what is good traffic to us
that is traffic coming from our CDN
provider that is traffic from our
headquarters and just and datacenters
it's traffic from other GCP projects
that is egressing and hitting API target
comm for instance and some trusted third
parties and then literally everything
else we don't want so we don't want the
Internet to come knocking we don't want
adventurous and crafty people trying to
get a have figure out what sales we're
doing ahead of time things like that so
this is where a cloud armor comes into
play so just to give you kind of a
graphic view of this this is kind of our
overall architecture right so we have
the ability for target guests and even
people who aren't guests or applications
and computers who aren't guests to
access our services through the CDN edge
and that will eventually make its way
through and then come in to our load
balancers now what we don't want to have
happen is this other traffic kind of
coming in from the side right and going
through or bypassing the architecture
that we've so carefully set up so what's
really useful in this particular
instance is basically applying cloud
armor just at the load balancer there
and so when this traffic tries to come
through again cloud armor just goes
ahead and blocks that for it for us so
eventually all this good traffic will
come through it'll hit the instances or
our kubernetes pods as intended and
those backends will never see that
traffic that we just don't want coming
through so once we start talking about
using cloud armor something that's
really important is how you actually are
going to use your policies we actually
have two different environments as I
mentioned earlier our non commerce
environment and our commerce environment
and they're laid out a little bit
differently so our non commerce
environments they're basically large
monolithic monolithic product of
projects that are multi-tenant right so
we have many different applications
running in these projects
the advantage in a single project is you
can deploy one cloud armor security
policy and have that apply to all of
your edge load balancers so for your
deployments that have many load
balancers this is really advantageous
because you basically have centralized
management of those security policies or
if you have special requirements for a
certain few load balancers you can
create a one-off policies and apply
those as well if you have multiple
projects and this is our case in our
commerce environment because we're using
a feature called shared VPC so in this
type of configuration what happens is we
have multiple projects that contain just
the applications that are intended for
that particular project and those are
bound to their own individual subnets
each project in each application in
those projects has their own load
balancers and so we need to distribute
those policies to each one of those
service projects and then bind them to
the load balancers so that means things
are a little more distributed and it
could be a little more difficult a
little more difficult for you to manage
luckily for us things work pretty well
we have a centralized terraform
repository that contains all of our
cloud armor rules and so we're able to
deploy those across our suite of service
projects pretty quickly so just to kind
of go through a blueprint of how we're
doing things in our non commerce
environment we essentially have a single
policy for all of our load balancers
that load that policy is effectively
what I had just mentioned a few slides
ago we use terraform to centrally manage
that policy and our application teams
and our platform services teams use an
open-source tool called spinnaker to
create and manage their load balancers
and also to deploy instances we
currently have an out-of-band process
that goes through and attaches security
policies to those load balancers created
through spinnaker in our commerce
environment things are a little
different we're much more aggressive
about the security policy there around
posture obviously so what we do is we
have a policy per service project and
that will attach to the load balancers
in that given service project again we
use terraform to manage these policies
and what we do is we actually abstract
these policies from our tenants so when
our tenants use terraform to create
their load balancer
what's actually happening is there's a
terraform module under the hood that
contains the claude armor policies and
it attaches it to the load balancer so
effectively when we have one of our
application teams create a load balancer
through terraform the cloud our security
policy and SSL policies are
automatically applied like day one so
there is never a concern about a load
balancer that wouldn't have these
policies in place so then just to kind
of wrap things up there with our load
balancers we take all of the stack
driver logs including all of the cloud
armor logs and what we do is we use
logging sinks to bring those back to our
data center once there our data center
they go through a series of Kafka topics
and subscriptions and we ingest them
into target security infrastructure so
using that and looking at the type of
traffic that's being blocked by cloud
armor we can actually gain some insights
into the type of traffic that's
happening there and detect any possible
attacks that someone may be launching so
if we rewind to our cloud journey in GCP
in fall 2017 cloud armor was in its
pretty early stages but we wanted to
have a defense mechanism should anything
occur so again we were ingesting logs
and our security operations team was
basically analyzing those and would tell
us real-time if we needed to take any
sort of action our cloud armor policy at
the time was tactical blacklisting so by
that what I mean is we had a rule set
that basically was written to allow
traffic and then left space in the
middle that specifically denies
particular traffic from particular
sources and then the default rule is
allow so in this way we've given ourself
room to create deny rules but we aren't
going to stumble and accidentally
blacklist one of our own addresses and
cause big problems one of the
interesting pieces about this because
cloud armor was in alpha we had a few
folks that were a little concerned at
target about how this would operate
would its scale and our Google partners
mentioned to us that this is used at the
Google edge for a lot of their products
and so that helped out but there was
still a little bit of concern and so
what we did
is we actually applied this policy to
all of our endpoints and we didn't tell
any of our application teams that we did
that and no one noticed a single thing
and everything went off without a hitch
so that was the kind of proof in the
pudding for us that cloud armor really
does work when we talk about how we're
using cloud armor today we're shifting
to a tactical whitelisting approach so
by that what I mean is we have several
rules in place that allow all of the
authorized traffic that I mentioned
earlier traffic from our CD ends and
data centers and things like that and
then right down at the bottom we deny
everything else so in doing this we
really restrict that to those approved
endpoints and through the architecture
that we've so carefully set up with
laughs and caching and all those great
things at the front end so we have these
security policies deployed to almost all
of our load balancers today and we have
just a few that we need to flip from
preview mode to enable mode and block
that traffic so just another tip of the
hat so the preview mode feature of cloud
armor it's worked really great and it's
helped our application teams identify in
some cases traffic from some of our
systems that they didn't even know was
hitting those endpoints so it's been
really great to help understand traffic
there just to kind of go through quickly
some lessons that we learned obviously
defense and depth is a thing so adding
cloud armor isn't going to fix
everyone's problems you obviously need
to take quite a few steps but it does
help in terms of you know filtering out
some of the general traffic out there on
the Internet we learned a very important
architectural anti-pattern and that is
egress ingress hairpins so in our
environments of GCP we operate naps so
most of our instances don't have
external IP addresses and in some cases
we reach out to parts of AP at
target.com
that also live inside GCP so we have
this really nice kind of hairpin going
on and that can make it difficult to
write a cloud armor policy especially if
you're using items that auto scale and
so you don't have predictable IP
addresses so that's something that we
learned and and something that might be
good to avoid
another item which we're working through
right now is retro actively applying
policy it turns out if you start really
restricted and then open things up a
little bit people are happy with that if
it turns out that if you start with
things fairly open and then try to
restrict that sometimes people aren't a
big fan of that
so starting secure by default and day
one is a really great thing to do rather
than trying to apply that over time
finally just as kind of a last few
points here
organizational inertia can be hard to
overcome so this kind of again goes
towards that retro actively applying
policies point so in every company in
every business it's a little bit
different but sometimes can be a little
tricky and then there are a few
scenarios that we've encountered that
don't quite perfectly work for us and
we're still researching and trying to
think of good solutions for the biggest
one for us is our users with split
tunnel VPNs so when you're working and
from the road or at home your laptop
will connect a target and send traffic
intended for targets internal items or
internal end points over the VPN when
you are going towards one of these
public endpoints or one of these
external endpoints it will not go over
the VPN you won't have a target IP
address so you'll be blocked so we're
still working through some of those
pieces and working to make that a little
more predictable so that those users can
still get their jobs done while they're
working from home or elsewhere so as we
look towards the future and things that
we're excited about pretty much
everything projected just said we're
looking forward to a lot of things and
one of the most important pieces that
we're looking forward to is the ability
to automate policy enforcement so if
someone creates a load balancer in our
non commerce environment that for study
or perhaps another tool we'll pick that
up immediately and attach a policy to it
so we don't have to worry about that so
with all that said I'll turn it over to
silo who's going to talk through quite a
few interesting new pieces of cloud
armor thank you
[Applause]
hello good afternoon so far predictor
and Nick talked about protecting your
cloud services using cloud armor for
known predicted attacks you can use IP
whitelist blacklist to block or allow
some traffic and you can also create a
geo based access rules geo based access
control rules as well as SQL injection
protection as well as exercise
protection and taking one more step with
cloud armor you could also create custom
rules to prevent attacks from let us say
a known hackers or known attacks but
what about the protection for the kind
of attacks that you did not anticipate
globally attack volumes are growing
multiple times and there's also an
ever-increasing risk of high-volume
attacks from large amount of small BOTS
as well as large powerful hosts so let's
talk about some of the existing
strategies your network security
engineers will apply for protecting
again as these large attacks number one
you could increase your serving capacity
to multiple times but some of these
attacks are so big no reasonable
increase in capacity will actually
protect you against these attacks and
you could set up volume thresholds but
the problem with the volume thresholds
is that when the attack is four times
five times bigger than your baseline
volume then you are allowing more attack
traffic than the genuine traffic and
thirdly you can set up an analysis of
the logs as well as set up some
statistical algorithms to run through
the logs and come up with rules but the
problem is by the time to react to this
attack and come up with a rule that will
isolate the attack traffic your service
meal already experienced downtime
what if a system exists such that some
of these attacks can be detected
automatically and such a system can also
detect and isolate the signatures of
these attacks and come up with rules for
you to block or throttle the traffic and
let me introduce Claude Armour III at
Claude Armour we are leveraging Google's
innovation and deep learning as well as
AI to come up with DDoS attack
protection system that hope that will
not only detect but will also provide
protection in a timely manner so you
have seen the demo of Claude on a few
minutes ago projector demonstrated to
you how to write the rules and how you
can apply them and protect your system
so today as it is Claude armor will
protect you against SQL injection as
allies XSS threats and you can write
your own custom rules for some of the
known attacks that you faced in the past
and you can do IP whitelist blacklist
for for allowing or blocking the traffic
so let us say hacker planned an attack
on your system and that falls into the
existing spectrum of the rules that
you've already created claude armor will
effectively block all this traffic your
systems are healthy and life is good and
no blaring pagers right here comes a
quickly ramping up bot attack and the
way this bought it hack is structured is
that it it rotates through multiple user
agents a set of multiple user agents as
well as referrer URLs and coming from
one or two IP addresses and this attack
will quickly overwhelm your services if
the volume is big and your pagers will
go off and what would be the strategy of
your network engineers here they will
have to go through the logs and they
will have to set up a statistical
analysis
to goad sift through the logs come up
with isolating the signature you may
have spent any time between an hour to
several hours and your service will much
probably experience some downtime with
cloud armor AI most of this toil can be
avoided cloud armor leverages deep
neural networks architectures to detect
the attack and isolate the signature as
well as come up with rules for you to
block the attack in general deep neural
networks are very efficient they allow
us to predict these attacks with a lot
more accuracy than regular machine
learning algorithms and they also allow
us to fast train our attack models and
we will also be able to do distributed
training of these attacks attack models
with large datasets one scleroderma a
isolates the signature of the attack it
will also generate an alarm and it'll
also create cloud armor rule for you to
apply and block or throttle the traffic
and once your network service engineers
received alert for the ongoing attack
they can actually go to to cloud armors
the tag console and check the signature
check the rule and apply the rule so
from the time you apply the rule it may
take few minutes for it to propagate the
policy to be propagated to all of the
load balancers but from the attack to
the defense it may take few minutes from
the time the attack ramps up the
advantages with this system is that you
don't have to set up service threshold
thresholds and and it's basically you
don't have to worry about your periodic
traffic variations cloud armory I will
will train based on your traffic model
and also the traffic patterns and it
will ignore any periodic patterns that
that your service may experience for
example you may experience peaks in the
morning
and in the evening and those will be
ignored and will not be flagged as as
attacks it's basically designed to
reduce the toil and as you see Clara
Dharma AI is not one thing it's
basically the whole pipeline weaves
through multiple machine learning
algorithms and provide you the
protection as well as a quick detection
of the attacks let's do a demo of cloud
armor AI here is flawed armor a eyes
console and this is the traffic analysis
console as you see here your services is
fine you have a baseline around 5,000
QPS and and the top part shows you the
attack traffic and currently there are
no attacks so everything is good and on
the top as you see here the console
shows you the total cumulative requests
as well as the allowed requests and it
shows the blocked and predicted requests
and here is your defense console so far
systems are normal
everything is good now let's initiate an
attack so we've talked about the attack
previously it basically weaves through a
lot of user agents as well as referral
URLs and let's launch the attack on the
service and let's see what happens and
if Kurama AI will detect the attack or
not so once you launch the attack let's
go back to our traffic analysis tool and
as you see here you will hear you see
towards the end there is a peak in the
volume but cloud armor hasn't detected
yet so you may take any time between 30
seconds to 2 minutes for claw Dharma AI
to pick up depth there is an attack
going so as you see here the attack
volume is ramping up and it's going to
6500 QPS or so and it's slowly ramping
up to 9000 and 14,000 and there you see
claw armor the tech ting an attack
it's not only detecting that there is an
attack but it also gives you a
classification of what part of your
traffic is attacking word is actually a
genuine traffic and as you see on the
top here on the top you will see the
predicted attacks now we can click on
the the spike over on the predicted
attacks and we can actually see what is
the characteristics of this attack as
you see here so you you have the attack
coming from through IP addresses 50% of
the attack is distributed to one IP and
the other and you have referral values
basically taking up some of the volume
and it's not only the referral value is
some one of the primary characteristic
of this attack is also user agents so it
will assign what kind of volume is
coming from each one of these so the the
advantage of claw armory is not just
detecting the peak right any statistical
algorithm will be able to detect the
peak but here you are able to detect
that this is an attack and you are able
to characterize the attack and come up
with a rule and here is your console the
defense console you can see that the
service is under attack and also the
attack signature it shows you what are
the prominent features of this attack
and here we have the remote host user
agent and the referrer URLs and it also
suggests a rule so you've pretty much
reduced your attack response time from
hours to minutes here and then once you
see the rule you review the rule you can
go ahead and and click on the rule to
apply and you may take few minutes for
the load balancers to load balancers to
apply the policy so that concludes our
army AI de Muro so back in September
2016 Evernote announced that they are
migrating from their on-prem to Google
cloud and post the completion they have
given as a
a really big endorsement saying that
they not only match the on from security
with GCP but they were able to surpass
the security levels they experienced at
on-prem so he this is a great
endorsement for us and it's not only
evernote but there are several other
customers using cloud armor to secure
their deployments and our goal today
here is to share with you some of those
are some customer experiences as well as
demonstrate that GCP is a secure first
network we are investing a lot in to
making your services secure and with
cloud armor and cloud armor a I you can
not only secure your GP services but
also reduce the toil in protecting your
services and and you are basically by
using cloud armor AI you are you are
outsmarting your attackers
[Music]